speaking of lawyers the Minnesota
Attorney General Keith Ellison actually
warned Target about their obligations to
lgbtq individuals and of course we know
that means the lgbtq lobby that's what
they're referring to whenever they talk
about this community so this was not
just the Minnesota AG there was a
coalition of 15 AGS and they reached out
to the CEO of Target to offer support
after the pride backlash in an open
letter where they said and I quote and
you know please stay sitting
we understand Target recently pulled
some pride merchandise from its shelves
excuse me from its shells out of concern
for worker and customer safety the
letter says that's while we understand
that very dangerous merchandise it's
extremely dangerous merchandise it's
gonna jump off the shelves on tacu
exactly it could implode into a hole oh
okay I forgot so they released this
letter where of course what they're
saying to Target is we understand you
know why you were afraid of course the
right wing in this country is just
absolutely out of control you remember
those riots that lasted for a month at a
time that you know that uh that
far-right group must have perpetuated we
can't get to the bottom of it but the
Minnesota AG Keith Ellison wrote to
Target warning that their decision to
pull Pride Merch this is from Fox by the
way
um this is their wording from stores
encouraged bullying and will embolden
hateful methods so hateful methods and
bullying I would say if there was an
example of bullying in this story it
would probably be from the lgbtq
activist who sent bomb threats to Target
but I'm curious to hear all of your
thoughts on this
well we never want to empower bullying
in this country
um definitely the progressive left has
never ever tried to push its agenda in a
in a manner that would constitute
bullying they would never do that uh I
mean I I think this ridiculous it is
interesting that you know it is a
coalition of what 15 attorney generals
and the Minnesota attorney general is
there you probably already mentioned
this but uh Target is based in Minnesota
so there's a certain amount of pressure
to get in line fall in line with your
hometown
um it reminds me of the Bud Light
boycott in some ways because initially
it was the conservative saying we won't
drink this Anheuser-Busch you've gone
too far you're pushing inappropriate
things to underage children and and then
on top of that gay bar started
boycotting Bud Light saying how could
you not vocally support Dylan Mulvaney
and everything else that this community
represents and so we're seeing the same
thing here you know Minnesota is now
saying why are you not doing more even
though we will not acknowledge that
you've lost billions of dollars exactly
exactly and so I mean there's just so
much to pull apart here firstly Target
obviously has a fiduciary responsibility
to their stockholders to ensure that
they're not tanking the price of their
company and the valuation of it so that
the people who have invested their money
in them aren't you know completely Sol
and that's not something Mr Ellison
is particularly concerned with as it
turns out no the obligation is to the
lgbtq community here uh and what they
were saying of course in the the letter
was that they understand that there was
a legitimate threat to the safety of
consumers at Target no it was it was the
consumers who said they were no longer
interested in what Target was pushing
here that's the problem what they're
upset about is the fact that people were
willing to stand up to this massive
Corporation and say actually we're not
interested in having you force this
nonsense onto us and our families and of
course they call that a threat to their
safety and then they try to turn around
and say this is a threat to the safety
of our customers this is a very
um textbook left-wing tactic to just
project what they are trying to do is
have a predatory relationship with their
customers where they force any idea or
perverse set of lifestyle choices onto
those customers and they do nothing
about it so they're the ones who are
actually a threat to the safety of their
customers they're the ones trying to
victimize them in a very real sense when
those customers turn around and leave
they say well the customers are actually
being victimized by virtue of the fact
that they're no longer shopping in our
locations because the only explanation
for this is is Big Bad right-wing
terrorist or whatever other Boogeyman
they want to invent to avoid
accountability here yeah I I wonder too
it's just so arrogant of these attorney
generals to not acknowledge that by
telling Target you have to keep this
merchandise on your shelves for everyone
to then take pictures of and share how
it's not selling uh I mean I I think the
bat one of the best things Alex Stein
has ever done is go to Target and try on
their tuck friendly swimsuit right like
they are I think Alex also feels that
that's one of the best things he's ever
done too yeah I think it's not burned in
my mind actually yeah you'll never
forget it his his feet is really really
changed since that experience but I just
mean you know when we again I'll draw
back to uh Bud Light what did we see for
the weeks afterwards pictures of these
these stacks of Bud Lights not moving
off shelves and we saw more cases of Bud
Light with these crazy coupons saying
basically please we'll pay you to take
this uh I I can see on a number of
levels why as soon as this happened
Target felt like it needed to pull the
merchandise and to to say was there
really no
aspect of bullying I know there was is
this a complete fantasy is it the way
you describe it it's a total fan no it's
nonsense their idea of bullying is you
didn't comply with what I told you to do
you didn't obey me that's what bullying
means to a leftist were there were there
even I mean for example the school board
The Bullying advice exactly the parents
bullying the teacher so yeah Playing
devil's advocate which I'm often paid to
do you're a lawyer yeah I get it
um
if parents become unruly or they refuse
to respect you know everyone gets two
minutes to speak and you went over or
you you're Matt Walsh and you're too
effective and compelling you know
but there there's a sort of an immediacy
and there's a sort of a menace I'm
in the most I mean this is pure
democracy in action but is there
anything even comparable to that were
there any pickets anywhere
oh in front of Target stores I think I
think people it's possible but my
understanding is what they're really
concerned about is just the fact that
people have stopped shopping there and
their stock prices plummeted I don't
know if they would be as concerned about
protests I think and I think a lot of
this is I think a lot of what's happened
with Target a lot of what has happened
with Bud Light isn't that there have
been you know right-wing organizations
getting protesters together it's just
that ordinary people have said we don't
want this anymore and we're not going to
purchase your product well not just that
we're not gonna go to your stores
whenever you go whenever you go to a
Target what do you see people there
dragging their kids along because these
are people who most of them are
caregivers and also people don't work
anymore so everyone's there with their
kids and all of a sudden kids are
looking at these displays and these
bizarrely configured you know articles
of clothing and asking very awkward
questions
and what they want to have happen is for
is for the normal to become
you should your your children should be
exposed to this your children should ask
these questions and guess what we'll
even tell you how you should answer them
exactly that's exactly right
unfortunately consumers still have the
power to boycott these organizations and
they would love to see that stop
unfortunately there are organizations
that we don't have the power to boycott
segwaying into our next story about the
United States government and the
Pentagon so you may have heard over the
past several days while we've been
taking a break from from Tim cast at the
Pentagon had a little bit of an
accounting error which resulted in an
extra 6.2 billion dollars for Ukrainian
military aid you know I really wish that
every now and again one of these
accounting errors could result in the
American people getting tax cuts or
money being returned back to us but it's
kind of fascinating how these mistakes
seem to happen in One Direction so the
Pentagon said Tuesday that they
overestimated the value of weapons sent
to Ukraine by 6.2 billion over the past
two years and I don't know I'm sitting
here thinking we can't afford not to
spend an extra 6.2 billion on Aid to
Ukraine and apparently they can't afford
not to have it because we're still
sending it over there they still get to
keep it and there's absolutely no
accountability I mean I can't imagine a
strategy more foolish for determining
how your National Defense or even just
expenditure is handled by putting it in
the hands of people who pay absolutely
no price for horrific mismanagement of
those resources well that's the theme of
our era is no accountability and
certainly no in the federal government
is ever held accountable
for things that they're quite rationally
expected to be accountable for
I was saying before the show as we were
uh you know talking about this that I'm
surprised the Pentagon even bothered
coming up with this story yeah since
when do they even care since when they
need an excuse usually they just say we
just decided to send some more they've
failed their last five consecutive
audits I mean they're still in business
yeah exactly can you imagine let me ask
you this as a legal expert are you aware
of any large corporations that have
failed five consecutive Audits and just
been fine business as usual
well failing an audit is a funny concept
you know I mean when when audits there's
that lawyer talk when audits when when
questions are raised by audits Boards of
directors have responsibilities to
follow up on those and they have a
fiduciary obligation to shareholders to
make sure that problems are addressed so
you're you're asking the right question
the problem with government is that it
is not only
a word for how people doing stuff
together yeah that's right that's what
government means it's just when we get
together or and it's not even just a
word for remember when we all got
together and accidentally gave Ukraine
an extra 6.2 billion when we all just
got together and did that that's what
government is what I'm kind of wondering
here is one of the things I've kind of
heard recently was that they
a lot of the stuff that was sent to
Ukraine it was actually was actually
the military was kind of happy to get
rid of it a lot of it was was outdated
stuff and you know it gives them an
excuse to replace those things with
interesting new and better stuff
uh and maybe it's like a clearance sale
but for military exactly right gotta get
rid of it yeah gotta get rid of it by
shooting it at or we're having we're not
shooting it of course we're not shooting
it these people are shooting it it
Salvage their independence and their
pride did not mean Pride this story a
different Pride but you did say uh this
story reminds me I don't know if it's a
meme or whatever I saw on Twitter of
like it comes up every tax season where
it's like the government you owe me
money me okay how much we can't tell you
that's right is it this much no to jail
like exactly this doesn't make any sense
to me because the government gets to be
like let's stick this place six billion
dollars in that conversation because I
think we will be coming back to it
tonight again also thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time